pleinement une fois les femmes qui
veulent demander si j'avais des
érections c'est pas les tensions les
copains et leur parler la première
pression à froid c'est ça on va
s'affairer en danger leur sécurité les
ont toutes ces bêtises moi ça n'en fait
respecter l'autre et françois chaque
fois ça vous fait par le team avait jugé
intéressant me faisait chier
concrètement parce que quand ils voient
que c'est la première question qu'on
pose grêle c'est dommage
et j'en sais il ya quand même quelque
chose d'intéressant mais souvent c'est
ce qui fut enfin si ce qu'ils demandent
en premier en fait y en a qui se dit ce
matin était avec lui mais vous coucher
ensemble vous couchez pas ensemble ça se
passe comment elles sont âgés que moi je
défende sirleaf et à ce moment là
m'avait jamais venu qu'était pesant
choisir je changer on va présenter et je
cite un terrible ça va être chouette ça
valait le détour et je découvre au fil
du temps à avoir vu
souvent le groupe pour moi ce sont bien
plus que tous peuvent les aider mais si
j'étais principalement habitué à occuper
de personnes âgées déjà
donc j'étais et je suis très à l'aise
avec les personnes âgées mais je
m'attendais pas à ce qu'il est trente
ans du coup la proximité déjà village
m'avait stresser un peu trop voyant je
m'intéresse année je commençais à avoir
des sentiments mais lui s'en douter pas
je faisais tout pour le cacher bonjour
je veux mais alors c'est moi j'étais
inconditionnel à minuit je peux pas je
fais pas ton amour est dirigée par roy
après 3 sur le cours d'eau et en son
club pour ce jeune homme envers la
personne en face enfin sur son masters
sont du coup c'est pas tout le temps
face au pack gersois soir je couchais
mais julie écoute on va mettre les
choses quand même la plaque parce que je
vois un peu ce qui se passe et
j'aimerais qu'on en parle parce qu'on
peut plus rester justement dans cet
entre-deux et puis dans ce comité
et moi je suis partie de toute façon je
suis parent tels que ça devenait trop
trop pesant contre eux pour ne pas
présent obtenu faucon tard
trésorerie on va parler et tout ce que
je savais que je devais me dérouiller
sentiment que ce soit et ce n'était pas
facile
on me dit qu'il est tombé amoureux de
moi et qu'il espère paris m'a dit je
n'espère pas que tu me dises oui mais au
moins tu le dire et je dis pardon et tu
le sais et et c'est là que j'ai répondu
non je peux pas à cause de mon travail
je travaille pour toi je veux pas me
mettre avec toi et puis il m'a dit ah
merci c'est juste ça c'est je peux pas
l'entendre m'a dit je peux entendre
n'importe quoi mais je peux pas entendre
ça pendant juste au cros autobuzz tu
veux du cou et m'a dit mais concrètement
tu es je te plaît aussi ai je dit oui il
m'a dit pas bien embrasse moi je suis
pour leurs solutions avec mon fils
c'était dur au début c'était c'était
compliqué parce que en était on était
très fusionnelle tous les deux donc déjà
de rentrer quelqu'un avec nos déjà ça a
été je pense compliqué et puis en plus
il
handicap et puis ces mains qui sont qui
sont un peu élevés d'entretien allaient
faire au début de ses mailles ne pouvait
pas lui serrer la main ils pourraient
pas le check et c'était un peu difficile
samedi je serai pas comment faire en
fait mais après j'ai su trouver une
faille qu'à d'aptitude obligatoire des
percus
quand je revois le début et maintenant
ça pollue c'est ça puisque en plus il
sait s'il faut dire aussi c'est que tu
espérais pas un enfant un jour il n'y
avait pas justement d'être d'être rejeté
par rapport à son handicap il avait peur
de pas savoir gérer
ne pas être en récession finie quand
fait pour s'occuper d'un enfant
frustration montrer des trucs de
bricolage mais je trouve toujours des
solutions ne fonctionnait plus dubos
valence
je le travaille ça parce que parce qu'à
au pop art eu mon lot fort m'occupe de
tous les soins déjà puisque matin ma
faut que l'élève qui prennent sa douche
faut qu'il fasse ses besoins ce qui ne
fait pas tout seul il faut que quelqu'un
pour le faire aussi il ya tous les soins
gmoch oh non non non je ne suis plus là
que disent les choses parce que des pas
l'étiquette astra blot du coup changé
ils sont tellement complices que je
pense qu on fait abstraction tous les
mac en fait on est tous en train de
régler ça qui est charlie fait les
choses correctement avec automatismes
mais je pense je vais même abstraction
de ce qui se passe dans les combats
entre andrieu et tout ça c'est vers fès
qui m'ont jamais gêné non plus julien
c'est moi et ont fait quelque 4000 fait
pitié n'ose pas bon c'est pas un truc
qui me gène sain qu'un matin on rigole
beaucoup
ma chère tu es mal c'est vrai qu'on
apprenne à des métiers à ce moment où
nous sommes je sais très bien que dans
cette phase que ceux du coup se mettre à
l'aise et moi je suis faire 5-5
du coup les matins sont faits d'un
rayonnement extérieur nous prend la sas
et médian français sont encore trop
basse est alors moi je serai tout son
appartement ou iphone je prive quelqu'un
pour faire rêver si c'est ça et ça c'est
ça qu'il faudrait changer là-bas juste
le besoin d'aller très étonné quand il
j'aime la personne batterie pour moi
c'est qu'au bout du compte la fonte
cerveau étant une pensée pour moi et me
consume pas mon bien-être
même si les normes de faire quelque
chose à ce gars est ce qu'ils devraient
pas besoin quelque chose de vouloir
épouser son fiancé vente a lancé karim
au couteau au niveau de la fatigue
l'impression que ça
mais handicapé en fin d'après midi comme
ça donc ce soir c'est pour ça que je
voulais plus parce que je me disais que
c'était impossible mais en fait avec
persévérance et la bonne personne ça
marche
la morphologie et puis c'est tout à faut
pas s'arrêter à des trains faut encore
réfléchir aux choses à notre appart pour
que ça marche et vivre on a que la vue